and so far more than 130 people have
been charged for taking part
in the capitol hill riot earlier this
month well yesterday the fbi arrested
two people here in las vegas for
allegedly being there as well
our hector mcgee is following this he's
live downtown with what we know so far
good morning hector
hey there alex good morning we are in
downtown because we also saw protests
here in downtown outside the federal
courthouse but those were peaceful
one of the suspects arrested is accused
of taking part in the right in
at the u.s capitol investigators say
they matched the picture on his id
to surveillance footage and earlier this
month hundreds of trump supporters
stormed the u.s capitol to disrupt
the declaration of joe biden as the
election winner
five people died as a result our i-team
discovered one of those arrested is
nathaniel degrave of las vegas
a surveillance photo appears to show him
outside the u.s senate chamber
he's in the middle of the image
according to the federal criminal
complaint
and here's what got him in trouble the
grave is accused of illegally entering a
restricted building
obstruction violent entry and
disorderly conduct an anonymous tip led
investigators to even more video of
degrave
that video allegedly shows him and two
other men
discussing the planned protest and we've
learned another man was arrested
outside the graves apartment yesterday
but we haven't learned
his identity we'll let you know as soon
as we learn more about the second person
investigators say was involved as soon
as we know more reporting live in
downtown hector mejia 8 news now